Alright, now that we've seen this in action, let's go ahead and use it ourselves.
What I'd like you to do is create a new canvas DOM object inside a
new div DOM object, that is then put inside the body element. To do this, we're
going to have to grab the body element by its id of body.
We're going to have to create a new element, using document.createElement,
both for the div and for the canvas, then we'd like to set their ids. For the div,
we'll set it to gameContent and for the canvas we'll set it to gameCanvas.
Finally, we'll have to append both of those, the canvas to the div, and then the
div to the body. You'll have to use document.getElementById,
document.createElement, the appendChild method of DOM objects, and the id
property to do all of this.